Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters and I'm going to share with you my journey that I promised you
This is for all my patients and to hopefully encourage you and to
Lift you up going through your personal journey of cancer shared with you about a month or so ago, then I'm in this whole boat with you
some of you made it made I know because you haven't watched the zoom calls lately, but I too have been diagnosed with cancer and I want to share a little bit about that so that it's an encouragement to you and you don't get discouraged. Oh my gosh, my doctor's got cancer. I came to him and he's supposed to be helping me and what's the deal here?
So I want my experience to be a blessing for you and I want to through a series of videos that are going to be outside of our zoom regular zoom calls to share my journey to share what I've been studying and trying to figure myself out.
So let me give you a little bit of history. Here's me right here. I like that picture of me. Actually, that's me, but I don't like that picture of me so much. So we're going to stick with that one right there.
Right there is about 16, 18 months ago, I would say started having a lot of symptoms, abdominal symptoms and just kind of brush them off. Sorry, but I'm very personable, very intimate person. I don't like to share my problems with anybody else.
I guess I've learned after 30-some years of practice that I'm here to take care of my patients and when my patients say, how are you doing? I have a tendency to say, I'm doing great and don't share any of my personal struggles or experiences with my patients. Good or bad, it is what it is. Maybe it's some learned behavior over the years, but it's very difficult for me to share my personal.
It will be very transparent with my health with anybody. You're my best friend who is my wife. It's very difficult for me to do that. So my wife and kids will strongly testify that that is true in my life. But I want to share it. I just feel like the Holy Spirit is just nudging me to share my experience with you, my patients, because
it needs to uplift you. God has allowed this in my life for a reason. And I think one of the reasons is to encourage you in your journey through cancer or whatever serious disease that you're struggling with.
So in my struggle to figure out what was going on with me, I finally discovered with about 98% accuracy what it is, what type of cancer I have.
Oh, I knew that I had cancer because of some testing that I did, but I didn't know the exact type. And when the IVG test came out, you know, I was very excited about it because it's a not invasive way to test where a person is at with their cancer because of the IVG score.
And I was the first one to do the test. So as soon as we got the kids, I ran the test, got my score back, and it confirmed exactly what I thought was positive for cancer.
But my score wasn't like horribly high because I had no frame of reference what score should be. It was positive in the cancer range, and I thought, okay, it is what it is. No, no surprise to me. I knew that I had cancer. And then when all you guys were starting to run your IVG tests, and we started to get your scores back, there was a little bit more concerning for me because my score was higher than all the time.
Almost every one of my patients. And you know, well, I am a lot of patients that are stage four, and you some are doing fantastic. So I came to us not doing well at all, and are doing much better. Praise God.
And my score was higher than most people. So it was a little concerning to me as we started to get more and more people, the tests coming in so we could get a frame of reference what the score actually meant in the type of cancer that the person had, and in the degree of a spread that they had the staging that they had.
So it's taken some time to kind of evaluate the objectivity of that. Well, that told me that I was in a little bit worse situation than I initially thought as I discovered what type of cancer I have.
There it is right there. There's a picture of my cancer right there. It starts with pageant cells in the skin, and it can progress over time.
It can stay in the skin like this. It's called extra mammary pageant disease if you care to look it up.
There's not a whole lot of data on it because it's quite a rare cancer, matter of fact, with the exact type of extra mammary pageant disease that I have, there are less than 300 documented cases of it, at least in literature.
Because it's a very rare cancer, there's probably 10 times that many that have gone undiagnosed or misdiagnosed over the years.
So, but in literature, at least it's fairly rare, even if there was 30 times that much, that still makes it a fairly rare cancer, so there's not a lot of data on it.
There was a recent study at Mayo on this cancer, and I think it was a 10 or 12 people that they did the study on, tried to fight a new drug because chemotherapy is completely not effective in this type of cancer.
Which confirmed my desire not to do chemotherapy, and it was really a confirmation from the Holy Spirit that I was listening to him because I did not have any desire to do chemotherapy.
But again, just like I tell you guys, if I had a cancer that would, that statistically responded very well to chemotherapy, I would definitely leave it on the table for consideration.
If you look at the statistics for this type of cancer, not to be overly morbid, but here's from the Mayo study, the overall survivability of this is the median survivability is 1.5 years, and the 5 year survival rate is only 7%.
So, that's real great for a metastatic extra memory, a paddy disease, and that's what I have.
So, oh well, it is what it is, and you come to terms with it. This kind of is a summary of our road when we're dealing with cancer anyhow, right?
We look ahead of us, and it could be very daunting. There's people ahead of us, there's people behind us, there's people that crash ahead of us.
The road never looks nice and smooth, and there's a lot of ups and downs in why the paths and we're trying to navigate this pathway.
I guess that's what I feel like, that's what you feel like, but I know that one of the purposes in this is you have to understand my obsession for the last 10 years has been my complete obsession, has been to try to figure out how to save people's lives when God sends them to me for care.
And as my wife would test, I don't have any hobbies, I spend time studying, that's all I do, that if I get off track with that God always brings me back to be studying about something else to be able to implement a protocol to keep a person alive and keep them doing well as best they can because every single person that comes to me I feel like God has put a responsibility in front of me.
And I don't say that in a way that I can heal anybody, but I say that in a way that God keeps giving me a responsibility to try to figure things out, seeking wisdom, he's put people in front of me that are much wiser than me, he's giving me the ability to study and read in a hugger for knowledge in that way, and that has been fantastic.
But now I feel like this is what he's got going on with me, even drives me even more so not that I am more important than my patients, but it even tells me that God has got bigger things for me.
So I'm going to read to you ten of a preface of a blog that I'm starting so that you can understand my journey and my desire to help you moving forward.
So let's just read this, this is just kind of giving you a history of intro to where I'm coming from.
And when I, this is coming back, I wrote this some time ago, so let me go through this.
There was a time that I needed to imagine the feelings felt by my cancer patients.
I'm empathetic by nature, which makes me a good doctor, I think, and I've had to share, had my share of physical injuries, broken bones, brain ankles, injuries with cancer.
I could imagine my patients fear, I could imagine their pain, I imagine their dread of an unknown future, and I could console them with verses that assure that God would never leave them, and that he desires to walk with them through their suffering, wherever it may lead, there was a time.
Alex sat in a chair adjacent to mine in my console room.
I shuffled through his CT report as he shared his desire to forego any more key with therapy treatments, but he was told that the last round was just not effective for the cancer had no progress to his liver.
I asked him the same question that I asked all my cancer patients, tell me your story, I want to know you and how you got to this point.
I have to be honest, this consultation was a little bit different.
It was just yesterday that I confirmed my own diagnosis and my selfish thoughts wondered to my own paid as he recalled that it all started in September of this year.
How great I thought September was just three months ago and you heard first symptoms of any possible ill health progressed from stomach aches to stage four into three months.
I've had my old symptoms for twice that long.
I don't know why I was surprised, there was nothing that I haven't heard before, but this time seemed so much more real.
I guess I didn't have to imagine anymore, there is nothing better than experiential knowledge in most things.
I could read every book written about Abraham Lincoln and become the world's best authority on his life yet I still don't know him.
I've honestly dedicated the last half of my career tried to understand cancer and I must say that I am more committed than most doctors.
My wife would say that I really have no life other than studying.
Each patient has done my textbook, their disease, my obsession.
I guess God's providential plan has an ironic twist in that now I've now become my own textbook.
Alex continued his timeline of events that shaped the last few months were clear scared by the sudden diagnosis he started with surgery, resected part of the large bowel and followed with chemotherapy.
The most recent scared shattered all his hopes where he sat looking for comfort, grass speed for a future.
I understood experientially now.
Will this make me a better doctor or will this keep me from being one?
Will my story be one that encourages many or will I be an example to the real doctors that standard oncology is the only way to go?
Well, the final chapter has yet to be written, so I want to ponder the details with which God cannot yet trust me.
But I do hope that the process may become a blessing to someone, someone somewhere who is searching for hope has been stolen away.
At this writing, Alex is still with us and as I read this a year later, he's still with us. His hope has been renewed, if only a little.
I'll ever understand why someone calling themselves a doctor would ever tell someone that they had X amount of time to live.
How arrogant have we become to think we know God's timeline?
I wonder if the bit of success that I've seen over the years in this practice has more to do with just renewed hope than all the therapies and diets and nutrients.
I wonder if more cancer patients die of a broken spirit than a broken body.
I wonder what outcomes would be like if our medical system weren't so broken?
If oncologists would work hand in hand with doctors like myself and if the patient's well-being was placed ahead of insurance documents.
Most of all, I wonder what God will do with this beautiful irony of the cancer doctor's cancer that I look forward.
Oh, ever so cautiously to the ride.
Yes, this is our path, this one right here.
And I'm walking there with you and I don't worry about the statistics that are out there besides these statistics here that are ever so grim.
Remind me of well, first of all, all these people did chemo. I'm not doing that.
I know my path and I know my savior and that's that's all that really matters.
So I'm going to walk this path with you over the next month's hopefully years I'm going to be sharing what I'm doing.
I have some new therapies that I've been studying and trying out and I'm going to share those with you too.
That's going to be encouragement to you and I'm going to try things that I don't like and don't work and didn't work.
I'm going to try things that do work and it doesn't mean that it's for you to use either but I will need to talk to any of you and I'm here for you.
And I don't have the worst symptoms in the world and a lot of you are suffering much worse than I am, but I'll tell you right now I have peace.
I'm going to ask this all understanding because I know that I'm in his sovereign will no matter what and my trust is in him.
Not in my wisdom and my knowledge and my study and all the things that I bring about here tonight.
But I'm not my wisdom and knowledge is coming from him and my dependence is on him.
And that I can rest because it's not my problem anymore.
This cancer ever was my problem and I'm not going to let the devil fool me to take it up.
That's his part. It's God's problem. But he's given it to me for a reason and I hope it's to be an encouragement to you.
So I'll keep up with these little blog posts and I will see you again very soon. Thanks much.